it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gonna keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when it was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do it right
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
let's go let's go is that a go-go duck
shirt this is a go-go i use
go i use that i don't i trust you still
use google google oh wow you're a cook
[Applause]
yeah you know that right like it's
science no they did a bunch of like
studies on it like people that just use
google
cop
well i am a cockney that's cool no i'll
admit to being a cuck but um
the the it is true that when albert uh
char richard what's up johnny murphy no
um who wrote the madness of crowds he
has a section in his book about how when
you michael pollan no well the madison
crowds um
he's great
doug douglas murray he's fantastic and
he says in his in his thing he says uh
basically
he he
google got so woke that when you
google
couple or you google family it would be
like you'd have to get every image was
of a black person with a white person
it'd be a black family it'd be too gay
like this with check please all that
stuff and then as you had even european
art
they had some obscure like painting of a
black person and you still subscribe to
it and it's like but but it was just
these people trying to push certain
things to the top google pushing the
narrative and it's like guys it's not
that accurate can you just be a little
bit more like i don't need your politics
when i'm trying to start something
searching i just want to search
something that's it that's it and go go
duck you know the problem with gogo duck
it's all i use
go right now i'm gonna [ __ ] go go go
duck because i'll oh you know i ever
surfing dude go go ducks my thing and
get rid of the randy doughnuts thing
because they those donuts suck you know
what at least get sidecar dogs you know
what they do suck they're not good
they're not it's not original la though
it's a whole la tat like i'm supposed to
yeah do a whole la thing yeah randy's
the only one
that's okay but to be fair yeah
not a good doughnut no it's not they're
dry no there's no nothing special my son
and i got to go to the hood for him yeah
on on wilshire there's sidecar donuts
and then there's randy's donuts my son
goes he goes let's go to randy stone and
i go walk in there i go
walk in there he walks in there i go now
hold on we walk over i go side cargo now
you choose which one you want he goes i
want this one well now to be fair though
randy's donut should get a donut for a
dollar twenty five side quarters it's
just about seven
bucks
it's a six dollar minimum of doughnuts
this is true oh you want the donut holes
like my fat ass used to eat you're
looking at twelve dollars for donut my
my bill came to about
35 because i i bought seven donuts oh
remember back uh in the day when we used
to hang off abbott kenny i wanted to
celebrate i forget i don't know we hit
10 million downloads whatever they're
going to get 12 donuts from side court
dude 112 dollars it's crazy excuse me i
went it's doughnuts for the other excuse
me donuts for the elite well also
worth every penny
and you get what you pay for because
randy's is the dodge neons of [ __ ]
you
pay for they taste like they're dry
there's nothing special there's better
donuts at ralph's or albertson like
they're they're crash by the way donuts
[ __ ] awesome but i have another man's
donut shop on my leg so
i'm a [ __ ] donuts are the one i'm the
cook i have a man's name on my both
[ __ ] your cupcakes use google i use
google
now duckduckgo but i use duckduckgo the
problem with duckduckgo is it's made
it's like the default like uh search
engine on this i got rid of uh google
so it's the default mode problem is it
doesn't remember anything so every time
like it's not going to remember [ __ ] oh
so every time you're in the the the news
but like it doesn't there's no algorithm
it doesn't remember anything so
i'm always [ __ ] uh my default is
safari so it or no yeah it goes right to
google google yeah
you can
like if you want i mean you can do the
settings on your phone i'm so lazy i'm
so i'll do it for you like i i parked my
car
and i had 38 minutes left in the meter
before you didn't have to put money in
the meter sure that was the end of the
day now i parked my car and i had to
walk
you know i had to walk to the restaurant
now all i had to do was put a credit
card in you have to go like this take
the credit out put it in a slot too much
and wait too much
it's too much i went
i'm not doing that my buddy goes
why
i go he'll get a ticket i go i don't
have the energy i don't even have the
energy for you to do it
we're walking away i don't have the
energy to tell you to do it to help me
out like me my son went uh hiking in
santa monica and you got to put you do
like the parking i just park and get out
and like run rush on time he's like dad
don't you have to pay to put the thing
like i see the people over there he's
six by the way
you don't have to pay to put the the
thing in the dashboard the time's money
dude let's get going so we go come back
fat ass take it yeah 75 no he goes dad i
told you i told you buddy time is money
time is money did you have fun on the
hike yeah i don't give a [ __ ] about the
day worth it yeah well i i when i go to
the beach you have to put money in it's
a pain in the ass you got to go pay then
take the stub and put it in your
dashboard i've never [ __ ] done that
once and i've never gotten a ticket and
so all the times i parked because i
don't have the energy i can't do it it's
too much especially if it's hot out it's
too much i'll roll the dice and when i
get a ticket it'll be 50 bucks and i i
paid 50 bucks for the year yes okay like
you you cop you finally caught me i've
i've robbed 12 banks i get con the 13th
cool i get away with the first 12.
remember my very gay prius it was red it
was oh yeah it was the purple yeah i
called it the red ram i like red like
this it was like a maroon it was a
barcelona red yep sure it was it was a
red ram we called it the red ram
and it was so it was it was so
non-threatening it was a dishwasher
there it is
i didn't get tickets i used to park
illegally everywhere i just did what i
want and i think the meter maze people
are like no
he's in a red prius
life is already tough enough i never got
[ __ ] with the interview was like being
punished already yes people would cut me
off dudes would cut me off yeah i was
just a com talk that's i was the biggest
[ __ ] yeah no i had a driver's license
that's a
[ __ ] cux r us cox ross can you do that
yeah
you get seven right cucks rs5
now did you watch the
speaking of being a cuck because i was
turned into one yes i don't know if you
watched nick schwartzen on
theo vaughn
i don't watch anybody else's but nick
was
he was like i'm brian i'm going to beat
him up when i see him
i'm going to beat nick up we're going to
get him on the podcast
and he's going i'm bryan count nick
schwartz and one of my favorite people
he's the best i love him
and then he's called you thiefer
mcsutherland which is hilarious he
remember when he came when he was on the
final kid back to the old studio yeah
and he roasted us he said i look like an
italian lego
nick is the guy i just talked the
funniest guy i just talked to him
recently he was he's doing some moving
but uh yeah i love him and he is truly
one of the funniest people on the planet
well i have a clip here so
let's set it up with the clip especially
for the people listening so it's a clip
of nick schwartzen and theo von talking
the title says nick schwartz and brennan
shaw both like fajitas yeah so there's
been you know whatever bottom dwellers
being like oh schaub stole a bit from
nick schwartz in the fifa mixer you must
have done a special on i don't know
about fajitas and i had a bit on fajitas
and remember my girls mexican right so
yeah but you wrote a lot of we had all
food mexican food yeah a ton of them
so the fajitas when i was saying how
embarrassing is like or uh bottle
service at the club like we know where
fajitas like
like geez like it's embarrassing like
everyone says steve has a joke and
watches you i'm sure
so
i do it's not especially anything i do
that bit at the comedy store i wrote i
don't know right before i went on right
so i do that bit maybe three times and
then some fan was like oh that's like
nick schwartzen's bit i know nick has a
fajita but he goes yeah and this is what
people don't realize comed the comedy
community is pretty
knit we all know each other so all i do
is nick is a friend that's text and go
hey man heard you up fajita bit i have a
new bit that i wrote about fajitas you
have fajita videos i have something like
it what's your premise like fajitas how
embarrassingly were fajitas it's
sizzling it's like we're in bottle
service of the clebus not exactly like
not exactly like mine i can see how
people see it i went all good not going
to do it anymore
i've done that so many times
i had a t-rex joke and there was a guy
who did a t-rex joke and i realized it
was just too close so it used to kill i
stopped doing it and by the way i'm
never worried about writing i had seen
it i had seen it before that so it's
like justin mckinney justin mckinney's a
great comic and he had this [ __ ]
hilarious bumblebee joke where he's like
if you see if you see
a [ __ ] car on the highway with the
doors open
and it's empty it's because there was a
bumblebee in my car or something like
that yeah it's genius i had seen that i
wrote i wrote a wasp
killed it i remember it was different
enough but let me tell you did was it
was i influenced by justin mckinney i
don't know parallel thinking yeah well i
wasn't even influenced by nick zorza
i've never seen i've never seen his hour
i've never seen i just know i i don't
watch a ton of comedy i've never seen a
special i've never seen anything you
don't steal we've had them on so silly
but also it's not worth talking about
because it's hilarious but i love thief
or mcsutherland so funny and and um
uh but i remember when i watched kevin
hart i think it's called laughing at my
pain and he talks about his dad the
whole time i went i should start writing
about my dad and guess what i had 50
minutes on my dad that's how it works
man yeah
sometimes like i'll see a bit like i
figured what comic's doing a bit because
i had a bit about mexicans crossing the
border right about my wife yeah i saw
somebody do the bit and it was so good
yeah similar parallel thinking it was so
good about mexicans coming to america i
went i'm not doing that yeah but
sometimes i can't compete with that i've
seen that's the best but i went as far
as mexicans crossed the you know this i
think it's santino's bit about mexican
does the he does the i think it's into
he does the accent and everything i'm
like hey i can't do accents like that b
there was so much smarter intelligent
than my bit i'm good yeah i literally i
saw that i
mean laugh factor then probably went um
i'm not doing the i've done that and the
only common thing was about them
crossing the border and his was
so unique and such a good take it went
oh
no that's so much better mine i'm out
one of the reasons i don't watch i i've
never watched a lot of comedy is because
i'm always afraid of that like i'm
always afraid i'm going to steal
something or i'm going to see something
you know not steal it but just
subconsciously because you can see some
[ __ ] and it'll get in your head and the
next thing you know two years later you
write a bit
and you think it was a reason that can
come from you don't know you can't
control i haven't had that problem yeah
like you said either the only
parallel thing i've had is this fajita
bit but like theo said yeah i talked
theo yesterday he's like hold on you
think you are the only two comics that
worked fajitas and got embarrassed yeah
he's like dude
even before nick i heard a fajita bit
people who still jokes get found out
yeah and that's i was gonna say
especially in today's age like back in
the day like i'll name i can name some
comics i've stolen some of my friends
bits life catches up with them you just
you can't get away especially in today's
site with social media and podcast
there's no way to get away with it you
you won't have a career you'll get found
out and as you guys are both pointing
out
it's something that's on your mind as
the worst accusation you can have as a
stand-up comedian that you steal other
jokes so you guys are already guarded
against it whereas it's like i'll see
fitness like comedy videos and it's like
oh you're you're doing the exact same
video as somebody else because that
ethos doesn't exist
but in comedy you couldn't show up to
the improv the comedy store live factor
if you're stealing jokes
you get voted off the island they're
worse there's nothing worse you get vote
off the island if that was your thing
and there's guys that's their thing
they're not allowed in those
environments people steal premises
yes
yeah good luck there's a few guys i
don't
know
that's why i'm announcing my last day
here i can't work for
you can't work for thieves yeah you want
to play the clipper
you guys want to see the clip are you
good what club the uh it's it's uh the
theology theo and nick talking about it
which i think now we stopped i know we
saw it okay we played it right no we
didn't play the whole clip oh we didn't
oh oh okay hit it
brian
oh brian did that that's why i thought i
saw him
[ __ ] shop just sitting there hurtful
[ __ ] shop thief or southerland
yourself that's what i call him
no kidding i there's a bit about job
like i guess he said people say he stole
some fajita joke from me did he i don't
i don't care this is funny
i don't care if he did but i doubt it i
mean he's had fajitas
yeah a lot of people have had fajitas
yeah
but i haven't seen i don't know if i've
even seen i i haven't seen that joke
would know no i mean who [ __ ] cares
[ __ ] brian i mean i've done a million
sets together he would know beat him up
it's so funny yeah brian get [ __ ] good
my face nick's so funny nick's been
famous forever dude you know i was
watching last night that you were 21.
you know as much last night you're on
you i bet you have no idea
uh it was the artie lang it was uh
vice's the dark side of comedy so they
did roseanne which i realized she got
cancelled off twitter and then the next
episode was uh artie lange is the new
one and it's i didn't know you and him
were did so many skits together on matt
tv every skit they showed you were in so
when he did the baywatch pig thing yeah
they're talking about how [ __ ] up it
was for him and like that guy orlando
orlando was like i i didn't agree with
the sketch like what what's the irony
here that he's fat like you're we're
just poking fun out of fat so what's his
idea so yeah see they didn't say that so
arty lang says ardee was so artist says
he has the pig nose on and he was you
know they they rap but he had to do more
shooting like more takes for it and he
was in the
the the green room in his in his room
and he was doing lines of coke with the
pig nose on and he was looking in the
mirror going i'm a pig doing coke i'm a
pig
well there's no one which is hilarious
there's no one funnier than [ __ ]
already
video the sad thing is shortly after
they finished wrapping the pig baywatch
skit he od'd
i'm very aware and wrote a suicide
letter to his mom and sister he took
something crazy like 25 valium 25 like
uh
something else and then drank a bottle a
fifth of uh jack daniels and then
survived no no they orlando and somebody
else found him in his hotel room or
wherever they're staying
and they rushed from the hospital they
pumped his stomach and he you know
continued to do what he's doing now yeah
artie um
that was when i
threatened his dealer on that set look
and uh
i was anyway there's a long story there
i'm not going to go into it but i want
to say this about already artie is the
funniest i i believe there's zach
galifianakis and there's already lang as
far as naturally funny like the lebron
james of fun yeah artie's ability
to just come up with [ __ ] on the fly or
just tell a story i think is unsurpassed
i never met anybody with that that
reservoir of talent
he's also such a good person like really
oh [ __ ] he's such a beautiful person
but he just it was interesting because
bobby lee was talking about how tough
like the demand is shooting mad you know
mad tv like similar saturday live yeah
and uh bobby was saying he goes i was
sober for three years a week into
shooting that tv because it was so
strenuous and such so much pressure yeah
i relapsed a week it was it was a very
very
tough place to work because because
you'd be pitching an idea
and
your castmates were were usually making
fun of you behind
you could hear them going i don't think
this is funny and i the original cast of
mad tv
was some of the most talented
[ __ ] they were so you're on
which season b i was in the original
caster you're the the first i was in the
first two seasons of mad team i was in
the original
cast of baddest [ __ ] on the
planet wow and when i tell you that they
were talented and i was the least
talented and i was the least experienced
by far that is what was going on you had
phil lamar holy monster arty lanky and
mike
you had [ __ ] jordan peel david herman
that guy over there one of the most
talented people you'll ever meet in your
life ever
orlando jones unbelievable these were
the best and the writers were all the
writers from he was on
tv
who frank caliendo yes but that was
after me
but frank's you know i mean uh look at
all the the the list of people taryn
killem was 19 and that talented killer
simon hellberg they were all amazing
they were there so many really talented
people
so many you guys are like the red-headed
stepchild because of saturday night live
right yes especially back then where the
bad boys live was the big deal bad boys
and girls we we we were the ones that
you know nobody really [ __ ]
did much with but it was it was an
unbelievable experience man and they
were so [ __ ] talented they were so
they were just all so
um experienced talented and irreverent
irreverent i mean i would just sit there
and listen to the writers come up with
[ __ ] but already to be fair
he was it was babe watch was his idea oh
yeah they don't say this no he was so
creative he would come up with ideas but
when you're doing that many drugs
especially blow and you're in a pig suit
and you're freezing it was the it's the
coldest i've ever been because it was on
the beach yeah we were on the beach in a
wig and just shorts it's the coldest
i've ever been yeah i watched the bit i
looked it up and watched it a bit after
you run i mean you i didn't realize how
much you and artie lang were together
although oh yeah
as my boy i loved him when you i still
love him when you landed uh
mad tv i i know you i assume you're just
like yeah whatever
it was the biggest moment in my life
because um i realized that i would never
be an amateur at least i had made it as
a professional it was the biggest moment
of my life because it was in living
color mad tv and saturday live yes back
then and how competitive was it back to
also back then there was no youtube they
showed up they showed me the list of
people i beat out
it was it was uh to feel good it was a
1100 pages i mean it was it was
literally so competitive everybody and i
i made it i because i was so desperate i
was so desperate i was so
desperate i didn't have a plan b it was
life and death yeah yeah it was
literally life and death for me well
you're going to fail if you didn't get
that yeah it was the best audition your
dad was playing a private jet back to
like in new york wait me and my dad and
i at the time weren't talking much yeah
yeah yeah it's tough
um yeah it was a tough time but yeah i
was watching i'm like holy [ __ ] you
forget that you were on that i'm like
because you never talked about it like
holy [ __ ] that's right jew already lang
like just these monsters and monsters
[ __ ] monsters you almost have
forgotten and so i might be calendar
beasts
i met you by your special i watched it
last night oh yeah yeah we watched last
night oh good we'll talk i met i met
young joe rogan on on mad tv because he
was on there right came on as a guest
that's how we became friends bro the
funniest get
the funniest kid of all time we can't
play it is when uh you find out you're
like one percent black one eighth one
eighth african-american the octoroon the
octoroon you were dying bro
i could not stop laughing it dude it has
have you ever seen it mark i have it's
one of the funniest bits of all time
yeah so he's on this date at this fancy
restaurant isn't it obvious
and then the guy comes and you're like
oh
yeah oh because i'm black don't you know
i don't you think i know what a
mayonnaise sauce is
explaining
your white customers
dude i could not stop laughing and i was
really i was incredibly educated but i
was a black man yeah i also keep the
black man down you know yeah when yours
he's like oh you don't think i know
it's so [ __ ] funny
it was it was
i'm an actor
isn't it obvious i'm an actor
i think i must have been searching for
your sketches on mad tv like around when
i first met you because i remember that
was one of the first ones that popped up
you should never do that sketch today
like sarah lives not doing that sketch
yep it's so funny
and she's all would you please stop he's
all oh isn't it obvious they're treating
us different like second class citizens
someone octa room
and she's all what are you talking about
who's this white guy in the suit dude i
was laughing so i
i need a degree to practice microbiology
or whatever it was
thank you did you write that
no i didn't i i wish i had it's so funny
but you know you were always had you
always had your hand in it
it would come with a sketch yeah we
would all rewrite it and was it like uh
snl like you you could write sketches
and put it oh yeah yeah yeah you can you
could do it all i didn't do enough of it
but yeah yeah when you look at the
writers from snl it's nuts
louis ck was a writer conan oh yeah you
know monsters
myers
so many i mean the the so alex bornstein
who who was who created family guy who
was a one of the creators one of the
producers and creators from the
beginning i think she was that i mean
you know there's some amazing talent
that comes out of those because the
because the selection process and the
pressure like for you so hard you didn't
even be selected like if you're a
finalist
you're gonna have a career well think
about like clearly yeah when i was
coming up there were really only five
ten channels yeah and pilot season they
were it was so competitive
and then australia and then england came
in and then you know ireland and they
all had perfect
american accents so now you're competing
with all of them so when you got a job
and i when i would get a pilot it meant
i was gonna if it went it meant i could
buy a house it meant i was going to be
rich and famous so the pressure and when
you get it and you do it and they
wouldn't pick up the pilot and you back
to square one that was my life and
there's no other outlet like this you
can't go to youtube or whatever you know
that was my [ __ ] life that was
everybody's life
it was always but as much shade as we
throw on youtube and them suppressing
stuff like thank god for youtube because
well you're special like obviously
you're dealing with different
circumstances but you can still get it
out to the people yeah is that what 240
000 views yeah i'm saying so it's like
yeah okay cool did you guys watch it
yeah i wish last night yeah we loved it
dude yeah it's great but i think best
pleasure you've done good i appreciate
that i'm waiting to watch it with luana
i try to get her to watch a lot of
people are saying it's the best i think
i've done i don't know i think it's the
best you got to edit it you got to kill
all your babies right like i had 80
minutes and then you have to say that
was hard but yeah look i'm i appreciate
that it seems to be received very well
i'm an octoroon [ __ ]
now there's a lot of hurtful comments on
the page actually on your special saying
it's unbelievable what a senior citizen
can do and i was psyched dude he's like
take it back take it back leo comedy
goes you know little about comedy you
know did you see the video you made no
um i got it did you post it watch this
here's the thing bro let's take a little
break
because listen
this is a great segue because i need to
sleep hard tonight because i'm on a
flight i leave my house at 3 30 a.m
because i'm head to appleton wisconsin
tomorrow that's thursday friday saturday
appleton wisconsin and then next week
i'm in ontario ontario improv september
15th and 17th boston september 29th
through october 1st and we just
announced calgary calgary is calgary
canada october 26 says 27th on the site
all good it's actually uh calgary just
got announced and right now it's one
show only october 26th come get some
calgary canada a listen guys uh listen
before we get into our sponsor before we
talk i need my sleep because dude i
gotta i gotta i gotta bring heat
september eighth ninth and tenth yes in
raleigh that's when this weekend raleigh
good night good night san jose
california's next weekend can't stop
won't stop that's the improv september
15 16 17. spakan washington spokane
comedy club i got that the next weekend
september 22nd 23rd and 24th then tacoma
washington tacoma comedy club september
29th 30th and october 1st listen guys
we're going to need our sleep daddy and
by the way my special man tears it's
just dropped don't watch it right now
watch it right now if you but only if
you like laughing super hard for 50
minutes now and you're gonna laugh and
be tired and you need a great mattress
but just not any old matches yeah helix
sleep
mattresses please helix yes helix sleep
is a premium mattress brand that
provides tailored matches based on
unique sleep preferences right well they
have 14 they have 14 unique mattresses
yep that's right buddy they got luxury
models they got the big and tall for a
guy like you they even have one for kids
my son tiger sleeps on helix sleeping
he's a giant but you got to take the
sleep quiz
dude it takes two minutes you knock it
out side sleeper stomach sleeper hot
cold we got you covered you ship it to
your door right dude right to your door
you get a risk free 100 nights wrist
free i took the helix sleep quiz bro all
right and i was matched with the perfect
mattress because i want something that
felt pretty firm all right and i sleep
on my side and i do move around so they
partner me up with the perfect mattress
all right not only is the best mattress
i've ever slept on but the setup was so
fast so easy they deliver it straight to
your door for free 10 to 15 year
warranty what and you have to try it for
100 nights risk-free if you don't love
it i know you will but if you don't they
will pick it up and give you a full
refund don't take my word for it helix
has been awarded the number one mattress
picked by gq and wired magazine all
right give them two dollars off them
their first order and give them two free
pillows go ahead free pillows all right
go to helixleep.com fighter that's
hewicksleep.com fighter with helix
better sleep starts now made in the usa
by the way i need my vegetables i need
my greens i don't have time to eat as
much as i need though and i and i was
having a long talk with a good friend of
ours
guys name rhymes with ho hogan and uh he
was talking about how important all
kinds of uh supplements are do you need
a multivitamin you need minerals whole
food source ingredients super food dude
multi minerals probiotics no sugar foods
dude i got you covered man with my
friends at ag1 that's right ag-1f
athletic greens join the movement
athletes moms dads aunts rookies
podcasters what if i'm paleo what about
vegan
what if i'm gluten free one gram of
sugar less than one gram no gmos no
nasty chemicals tastes fantastic i mix
in eight ounces of water and your boy
hits the ground running to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you
guys immune supporting free one year
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs with your first purchase if you
visit athleticgreens.com
fighter right now again
athleticgreens.com
to take control of your health and give
aj1 a try now let's get back to the
freaking program yeah
i'm dr
i'm a doctor room
how about
i'm better than him
he's just chilling with his dog
he's such a dick
my god he's so [ __ ] so [ __ ] funny
i love chris yeah
dude i started watching i finished uh
that show
the uh impeachment finally got done with
it
man that didn't work out for anybody huh
didn't work out for anybody literally
like like uh linda tripp [ __ ] right
people would like disgust with her
because she recorded her friend she just
lied to her that she was her friend made
fun of her looks oh everything yeah uh
linda tripp the star like with her nose
she had a nose job and then did
penthouse and was just
destroyed in the media i i told my girl
like can you imagine how they would feel
through social media back then like
imagine monica lewinsky linda tripp if
there's social media and star was like i
didn't know i had a nose problem until i
came to hollywood until until i got you
know obviously once i came public with
this allegation like i didn't realize
that a bad nose she had a nose job she's
like i had no clue
so if i [ __ ] started getting on big
networks and then people like dude
what's wrong with her nose and she's
like wait something's wrong with my nose
it's crazy but also bring her up yeah
but
i don't know uh star uh type in
clinton's something star but if i looked
at her nudes last night not mad at him
all right i get why you do it and she
needed money she couldn't get a job she
couldn't get hired anywhere after she
came out
yeah ken starr was the skin charge
[ __ ] bill clinton did you have about
linda tripp with the nose or is that
somewhat different no it's dark the trip
was made fun of her being unattractive
and all that yes
but
so there's monica was it her no he took
a lot of [ __ ] man
but
yeah
the the interesting thing is uh
you know who knows how they dealt with
it
in real life like as far as hillary
clinton goes did they show she was mad
at she apparently i looked it up she
kicked them out and didn't talk to him
for like three weeks
you know she's ride or die you know
obviously she kills babies and orders
pizza but a pizzagate um but
they're you know there she is so it's
linda tripp
no no no no no no that's a different
person it's so hard when people do that
to you you know you're you're a woman
and type in star allegations bill
clinton
i hate that [ __ ] yeah but even linda
tripp had surgery too because people
made fun of her looks like saturday live
roasted her everyone roasted her i don't
think that stuff is funny i've never
liked it
i don't i don't know i just it's always
kenneth um
not jennifer flowers
i think that might be a joke that's ken
that's uh the problem is there's two
stars in the big star oh jo is it jones
miss jones type down the star report you
see at the very bottom washington post
chin the variable yeah okay click on
that no no no no no no
the one below that one
and what else is crazy to me is they
released the star report and just all
the details and all that [ __ ] you're
like what like to do that to monica
lewinsky like oh you [ __ ] her she's 24
years old 19. she's 19. when she started
she was 19 but when this came like when
everything came to light she was 24
years old it's like she was just getting
started man
paul jones that's who it is paula jones
nose job
she had a she had a beak on her
i remember but it's like so [ __ ] up to
do that oh yes
i mean come on and she was like i didn't
know i had a bad nose until i you know
got on tv it's like really awful you
know i have a mirror though yeah do you
not does your house not come with
mirrors right well you know you don't
you're living in a different see look at
that before and after right there
children on the far right you see uh no
no no no no no no down that one
i mean you know
it's a beak on the left it is what it is
man i don't mind it though
but how much better is the right though
it is better that's the truth that
shaman works for her face
you see girls do it it's like you did
too much no she didn't go full blown you
know like yeah i can't breathe out of it
yeah it's actually a lot better when you
actually look at it oh i just did she's
a person and then she did penthouse
but it didn't work yeah
not mad at the pictures at all like made
my girl looked up last night
but it didn't work out for anybody
including bill clinton
and you know kavanaugh was a big part in
that too pushing it the narrative he was
a beast with it really john cavanaugh
big time part of it what was his part
he was because they wanted to go for the
democrats so his whole thing was like we
quit being so nice to bill clinton like
let's hit him with like how many times
you get a blow job from you know uh
michael whiskey and
even ken starr like whoa chill do you
think no [ __ ] chilling there's no
chill he's like let's get this guy out
of here she's got a good body
oh no her pictures are yeah they're i'm
not mad at all but the reason she had to
do it and her she she couldn't get a job
she had a child so after she came out
couldn't get a job nobody would hire she
wants multiple interviews everyone's
like absolutely not so then penthouse
comes along officer like whatever 200
grand she's like yeah i need the money
yeah so she flew to la did it because
she had a kid remember
you could go on that far right once i
know there you go i don't know if that's
her though that's not just her special
[Music]
he couldn't i get it i mean kirby
brunette look me up yeah i'm not mad at
her at all but the thing i was saying
about this with clinton it's like
was he
did he commit adultery did he cheat on
his wife oh yeah
a thousand times okay that one's a lot
um did he do all that but nothing was
ever illegal till he lied about it under
oath
he lied about and that's what got him
impeached
he lied about it yeah he was doing some
things and it ruined it so many people
like that sacred space it ruined so many
people's life it's sacred space jfk did
well
he got dealt with though yeah
it was he paid the ultimate price it was
the beginning of the end of that kind of
behavior in a way right like it was the
beginning of like sexual harassment was
was was uh when clarence thomas was
being confirmed that was the first time
we had ever heard the word sex what
sexual harassment meant what that was
i'd say the meet two more did more than
that did i'm sorry because you're
talking about this is 90 what 93 98 yeah
so but it was all part of the movement
you know for yeah but still you still
had harvey weinstein booming back that's
what's in his head although that was all
going on my father i remember when
when sexual harassment was a thing and
they were wondering if anita hill was
lying or not my dad was
my father told me a story about his own
mother who would come home crying
because
you know this [ __ ] boss of hers her
job my my dad she was the breadwinner
and she had to she had an amazing job
and she could not get fired from that
job she couldn't she needed that [ __ ]
money and that boss
who knows
but that boss took advantage yeah and
who the [ __ ] knows that's a bummer but
my dad would hear her crying i don't
know so when you're when you're a kid
and then then you you know that that's a
real thing
you're not too happy with that [ __ ]
it'll it'll it'll it'll raise your [ __ ]
well that's what uh with linda tripp
like when you really look into it like
why would so adamant why would she do
this well
if you look into her history
her father was like a big deal in town
and cheated on his mother for like 16
years but everyone loved him so he got
away with it because you pay off the
servers and all that stuff and then
eventually they found out
but so and he left them when she was
like 14 i think just walked the house
with some other you know broad left the
kid the family the mom the sisters was
like see ya i'm gonna run with this girl
so then linda tripp grew up in that so
she's like [ __ ] this these guys and
nothing he paid no consequences just
left the family [ __ ] him over so
lyndon tripp had a you know she had a
deep hatred for guys like that and once
she worked in the white house so she was
like hold up bill clinton's like that oh
i'm going to get him yeah because my dad
got away with it this motherfucker's not
getting away with it you can see that's
why she did that he had a history of it
but it's actually only she explained
that like she didn't explain to any of
that
sexual harassment was a very very real
thing
forever until about 2017 and if you
complained you got [ __ ] fired or you
would never get hired again i think
what's funny without not funny but with
the harvey weinstein stuff is
some of these
you know some of these female
superstars in the movie business you
don't hear them talking
he made a lot of their careers
yeah if you look it up like the people
that went through that production was it
miramax there were people that you look
like
oh oh wow there were people look it up
there were people i'll say this as to
quote eddie bravo look into it but there
were people who knew
that this this pig
would destroy your career the way did
mira sabino if you didn't play button
ball yep and he was a [ __ ] pig in the
world and everything oh god and he just
looks terrible yeah i mean out of all
the guys i've seen him in person number
times he's [ __ ] disgusting he looks
like a guy he also smells bad apparently
yeah and had a deformed jacket
his dick was all deformed
oh just triple whammy yeah
great yeah so i got done long story
short i get done with the impeachment
series fantastic you got to watch it so
[ __ ] good the actors are great in it
and i said watch this new show i think
it's called the patient with steve
carell
bro
i'm three episodes in short episodes
like 24 minutes each some three or four
episodes in so he's like one of the top
uh psychiatrist therapist in the world
right he's like a well-known guy
and he sits down with this guy
and the guy's a serial killer oh my god
but he can't like and then steve carell
this isn't a spoiler alert steve krill
uh they've been seeing each other for
like three months now and steve carell
goes i'm frustrated man because whenever
i try to get in depth with you and get
to the the root of your problem you just
lie or finagle your way out or talk
about country music you're not telling
me what's causing all these problems you
clearly have anger issues you guys like
yeah i need to get better that he's like
well no the only way this works if you
start being truthful with me he goes
yeah cool next thing you know he wakes
up they get the serial killer kidnapped
him chained him to his basement
and he goes i'm sorry i have to use to
doc you know but the only way i'm gonna
get better like you said i start telling
truth i can't tell you the truth because
i'm just spoiled i hope no no no no no
no this isn't a trailer okay this is in
the trailer he goes i can't tell you the
truth because if i tell you the truth
you're going to go to authorities
because that's you have to legally how
what an interesting dude so he chains
him
and sits down with him and forces him to
get him to get better he brings his mom
down it's nuts i gotta say it's an
actual serial killer this is it's so
it's such a good idea oh it's good steve
carrell is a beast yeah he's a beast my
girl goes i can't we gotta stop watching
this yeah your mind she goes all i see
is grew because my kids watch [ __ ]
but he's a phenomenal actor i go grew i
go do you realize what's you steve
grill's from anchorman he has
he's from the office he's from the
grounds right he's from chicago yeah
yeah yeah actually second city
second city that's right city here is
the groundlings look it up i think it
was groundlings but either way my girl
is all i hear is grew i'm like oh that's
such a shame you never watch the office
you never watch anchorman like this
guy's in so much [ __ ] yep he's such a
good actor yep he really is i can't wait
to watch that second city yeah oh wow
marcus the reason i of course that is
because tina fey goes chicago between
steve carrell and stephen colbert one of
them was a huge ladies man but i'm not
going to tell you which one and he said
she said it on jon stewart and he was
like neither of them hopefully
well yeah and and by the way tina feys
are [ __ ] amazing oh my god like oh my
god jewish head rider on saturday she's
astonished 30 rock yeah so good like
you're like
all of them though stephen colbert steve
perrell well i ever tell you that i i
wanted i auditioned for anchorman before
steve carl anybody knew steve carell
nobody knew him yeah and i go i want to
i will the office but yeah no anchorman
was before that no no no no
i believe
it probably came around the same time
but oh man was like 2003 or something
yeah it was a long it was before that
because because
yeah yeah 2004
yeah and then type in type in office
2005 well they all might bring up the
office in england though yeah us
march 2005. yeah there you go around the
same time though yeah you're right
you're right b so so but remember but
remember when they were casting
anchorman it was 2002. oh probably yeah
so i call my buddy and i go you got to
get me in for this roll
it's just sick roll the steep trail like
and i'm like
[ __ ] please let me get i got other
stuff and then um my buddy gavin said
bob i'm sorry but he's gonna cast his
buddy who's the second city guy it's
just the way the business goes yeah i'm
like all right they're lost and then i
saw steve karen like oh he's supposed to
talk back oh he's perfect
well he's better than him and he just
did dude him as the anchorman in the
[ __ ] bruce almighty oh yeah like
how's he do that yeah fourth round draft
pick he's the first christian yeah yeah
you're not competing with that guy
that's okay
i'm telling you to watch it the patient
i'm all over it oh
i need is that hbo uh i watch on hulu
okay it might be fx but
that looks good i was gonna say you know
what's cool about the two offices is how
karel over time made it his own
character yeah you know oh [ __ ] it's an
original
i'm all over it
yeah the you're the trailer for b chin i
know we can't
use but
but the premise is i didn't give away
any spoilers
maybe let's take another little break
because i'm headed to appleton west
content my mind needs to be right bro
yeah my mind needs me too i'm gonna be
i'm going to be this week and i'll be in
the night carolina good night yeah let's
go out to next week
how do i keep my brain up dude you need
alpha brain you know when you're in the
zone and you're like man what is
happening well what if i told you to
take a little pill a little pill that
talks i'm talking about alpha get me in
the flow state yeah bro world-renowned
neutrophic
talking about sub-brain from on it right
now over one million bottles sold baby
that's right joe rogan says it helps him
form sentences better when he takes his
stuff he takes it every single time he
podcasts i've never done a podcast with
him including fight companion where he
doesn't dude unless if you're like i
don't feel jittery i don't like caffeine
cool this says caffeine free baby amino
acid alpha brain
free if you don't like alpha brain you
get your money back just give them two
weeks if you don't like it they give it
to you back man full refund no return
necessary save 10 percent off your order
by going to on it.com
f-a-t-k for 10 off your alpha brain
that's on it.com f a t k or swing by
your local walmart and pick it up so if
you don't want to go to your local
walmart you can easily just go to
ana.com
f a t k and get temper south alpha brain
you're welcome thank you let's get back
to us chatting about nothing have you
ever had fun
so that really wasn't set up because i
think we were thinking that that was
like dude i'm so all over that episode
one first
minute you're like serial killer
therapist got it yeah yeah i mean [ __ ]
and then well
five minutes it starts with him waking
up chained to the bed and he's like what
the [ __ ]
you're like oh i'm in
you know me i love i'm balls doing
serial killer stuff i'm like oh it's so
interesting i tell my wife i was like
there's not a therapist in the world
that can help uh serial killer they they
don't they don't play by the same rules
like mentally like they're sociopath
narcissists but they don't want that
part of their brain they don't they
don't have uh empathy like they don't
want to go to jail forever so what
they'll try to do is if you could give
them a way to satisfy the craving
they would take it so that they don't
have to well again this is alert
he loves his mom his dad was brutal so
he loves his mom so he has him and his
mom sit down and he goes
his mom starts crying like you gotta
help my son obviously has an issue like
i don't have the same issue he has you
have to help him and so steve carell
goes look at your mom man every time you
have that impulse to kill somebody think
how much you're hurting your mom and you
thought that would help him i don't know
i'm at the point where you know i'm like
i can't episode three i'm like oh i
wonder if that helps way too much
you know clearly not yeah otherwise you
don't have a tv that's a real compulsion
oh my god imagine that you're well i
told you that [ __ ] uh professor
who's doing a whole like
the whole panel on you know serial
killers being sociopaths and don't have
empathy and out of one out of 500 people
have whatever and he does the whole
trial within the classroom he goes and
now i'm going to tell you but but just
statistically one out of 500 which we
have 500 people in here 501 including
myself one of you will have the
characteristics of a serial killer
it turns out to be him yeah
he finds out like
weeks later like oh well that's like um
this guy kids were like yeah yeah he's
always like
this guy not loving
this guy richard walter who came up with
the essentially blueprint for how a
serial killer becomes a serial killer i
recommend reading the murder room have
you read that no so he is the most
prolific he is
he is the guy
who
specialized in sadism
and lived in that very dark world and
young young fbi guys be like i want to
do this and he goes no you don't you
think you do but you don't you'll be
destroyed by it you can't do it the
darkness you see well he did and he he
gets into that and he solved he's the
guy who would solve all these cold cases
and he's uh scotland yard would bring
him in to do that we know the guy who
created the term serial killer is john
douglas who's the the show mind hunters
about so they interview charles manson
and all the big boys but this guy this
guy would this guy was giving a speech
to the fbi
he was giving a a lecture right
on how to spot a serial killer serial
killers how their brains work how they
become serial killers how they how they
once they get to a certain point they
have to keep upping the ante starts with
animals then they go to yes but they
when they finally get to a point
that's when they become cannibals they
drink blood they don't do all this stuff
they have
they have to consume and it's
actually always sexual in nature it's
how they get off
and
as he's giving this lecture
fbi is giving a lecture
a [ __ ] suspect walks in
a serial killer suspect found out where
they were
and he comes in they want to see what
they're doing and as he's talking
he looks over and he goes he stops
and he says
your suspect's in the [ __ ] room
they've been working on this case and he
goes your suspect's in the room
now why was he there and they and they
couldn't arrest him they had to get him
out of there
they said get out of here you're not
authorized to be here now why was he in
there
because he wanted to learn about himself
jesus because he was a mystery to
himself and this is exactly the same
thing he was a [ __ ] mystery to
himself and if you read this book the
way he breaks [ __ ] down oh yeah scotland
yard so they you know scotland
it's called the murder room look that up
scotland scotland yard throw prom huh
yeah scotland yard answer is uh
you know what scholarly artist it's the
fbi for england
do you know who they are okay so they're
like the fbi they're they're so mi6 is
the cia in in the cia can't be right jim
this is the sherlock holmes the murder
room that's it with sherlock holmes
well it's not the heirs of sherlock
holmes in other words that's just
theatrical but
um
it was about sherlock holmes on that no
that's that's that that's it right there
oh okay so about the father of modern
science forensic science yes it'll be oh
that's cool it'll blow your mind
but richard walter is the fbi profiler
yeah
it'll blow your mind
um
yeah so
so he he he they bring him in
they bring him in uh to scotland yard
which is the fbi for england you know
scotland has they they solve all the
biggest crimes we'll pick that book up
for the road right now and they uh and
so you you can't bring an american into
a bunch of british detectives who have
that much experience like get this yank
out of here yeah it's just how people
are trying right we're better but yeah
so this is how he uh this is how he
[ __ ] uh they've been working on a
case for nine months
and this is how he got all of their
their [ __ ] attention
there was a crime scene
the
barber
had his head smashed in
his dick had been cut off and thrown in
the trash can okay
how do you solve that problem who did it
okay it took him nine months to solve
the problem
back then i'm assuming this wasn't back
then this was fairly recently this oh
okay in the 90s okay but still no dna
science like technology they didn't know
fingerprints they had to find out who
had done this okay okay i like
and so
they just showed him a picture a
panoramic like a a picture of it of the
crime scene yeah okay and he stood there
and stared at it for about six minutes
and he goes
oh okay
the barber molested a kid his hair he
used to cut he was friends with the dad
the dad found out killed him came in
smashed his head cut his dick off threw
it in the trash
that's what happened
boom wow right on
and he goes through why he did that and
he goes through he can look at a crime
scene these guys can look at a crime
scene and tell you oh this guy is very
muscular and he has sex with uh women in
this position this guy has a stutter
this guy had a speech impediment this
guy works in a library this guy will be
a hundred less than a hundred miles away
living with his mother jesus christ in
his basement every single time he was
right because the way you commit a crime
the way you like this guy killed his
family and he lined them up like
cordwood and with their eyes pushed like
he had their faces pushed away from he
didn't want them looking at him
this guy would be living with his mother
and he's delivering pizzas how do you
know that a thousand different tells
when you commit a crime you leave a
family what a set of skills it's it's
such a set of skills well me marketing
i'll tell you you're [ __ ] like i'm
buying the i'm leaving going here going
to barnes noble buying the books so i
have it for the my flight's at 5 00 am
tomorrow that's cool appleton because
there's no direction daddy's on his way
to raleigh i think i have a similar
flight dude oh right well appleton you
got to use it at 5 30. so i fly i leave
at 5 30 a.m that means i'll be up at
three i'm gonna get sick from that so i
get up at three
leave the house by three thirties three
forty five
flight leaves at five thirty i didn't
know they'd leave that early sleep at my
house and and my brother booked it i'm
like five thirty's like what else you're
getting at my house i'm ten minutes away
nightmare
yeah brendan sleep at brian
house i'm 10 minutes away it'd be easier
for you i don't mind you waking up early
here's the thing honestly with with no
truck because there's no traffic i like
leaving early rather than late there's
no traffic i do report 20 minutes so
daddy would do this
daddy would fly to chicago rent a car
drive an hour and three hour drive
or you can fly to chicago and then take
a puddle jumper that's like 40 minutes
to appleton that's what you're going to
do or a three hour drive that's what
we're doing yeah
sorry see you see come on out appleton
probably north carolina i got a direct
flight
but then next week daddy's in ontario so
i get to sleep in my bed now that drive
you'd rather take a 5 am flight in a
puddle jumper then sit in that traffic
ontario pay for a helicopter that's
where if i wish i had the uber chopper
i'll do oh my gosh i wish i had the
money well you're not playing ontario
are you if you have that money no i'll
be in san jose california the weekend
after that i'll drive it's a great club
the manager there's a close friend like
he's my boy he's english
good man he's english yeah so whenever
joshua fights it could he god break it
down for me he's the only guy who'll
leave a 10-minute voice note on why
joshua won't beat usyk he's like no
you're wrong okay
so okay does usyk have a chance against
fury yeah he's so good for sure yeah
yeah his fundamentals are stupid stupid
how about this dude this weekend is uh
nate diaz hamzad
that's saturday
and they have 21st in uh versus the
leech jingling
damn tony ferguson at 170 too i don't
like they did so there's two mismatches
on this card and those are the
mismatches so then this is talking if
you're a draftkings fan so mismatches
mean for bettors
you have two big dogs you have hamzat
who start off as a minus 2400 he's down
to minus one
seventeen something like that one one
seven seven five now i think but uh why
is he why did he
because nate ideas is more famous that's
how betting and mma goes so real betters
will tell you don't bet on mma they
don't make their money on mma there's
too many ways to lose okay they've been
on nfl nba
you know mlb hockey really mlb's the
best for betting
because they're professionals and they
there's no
there's not that many ways to lose but
in fighting
hey nate diaz could damn he's minus
10.50 now that's the power of the nick
diaz fan base and they dis fan base
because people like i'm ride or die with
that guy well it's the most popular guy
is going to get movement so they set
those lines to get movement so you have
hamza so nate has a plus 700. and uh lee
chris handling is fighting song not on
this card that's a waste from that
that's a tough fight for court but um
yeah yeah i don't know the song oh my
god
chinese savage yeah yeah he's he's
artificially created in a lab okay he
looks like uh [ __ ] justin bieber
jinglang is he the one who comes out
choked out yeah okay he's a savage so
big strong guy yeah it had bigger
enchants so he's they're both like
rottweilers so for
tony ferguson first fight 170 to go all
right here's uh jingling here's the
leech like what guy needs a win what are
we doing here dude why isn't it then
kevin holland daniel rodriguez i think
best buy in the car stylistically yeah
and but it's at a catchweight of 180.
okay but daniel rodriguez's hands he's a
[ __ ] kevin's just such a crazy
athlete but i don't know man i wouldn't
just take him as an athlete you can't
fight yeah he can fight he can fight his
ass i'm saying but but that guy told me
again white announcer
he can [ __ ] bang and his his kevin's
like real flashy like he does a lot of
cool stuff but but daniel's no kevin can
fight it yes he can fight he's not
flashy kevin's fundamentals are [ __ ]
i got i got i think i got daniel
rodriguez in that fight he's a dog yeah
he's a yeah i mean kevin's gonna fight
that [ __ ] time now kevin
i'm sure has been working on his
wrestling but with the aka yeah aka now
darren regas is a wrestler
this will be a bang i think it's fight
of the night do you think that they
stand they stand and just bang oh yeah
yeah if he goes down it'll be because
kevin holland shoots
but uh
yeah hamza uh nate diaz and nate diaz
did a sit down like our interview with
brett akamoto
it's interesting because he's you know
in that interview you can tell you know
he doesn't like uh like the attention
stuff like that he's just talking about
how the games change how you know guys
before he was like if you'd see like bj
penn or you know hoist gracie in there
like in the airport in the mall how
their superstars they shut it down he's
like he's like champs now they're just
doing you know they're working for the
man they're doing whatever moves making
the most money he's like i don't work
like that so i don't believe in belts i
don't believe in their win loss system
you know oh it's cool guy very old
school
uh let me ask you
the game just doesn't like the games
past that native uh you know
ten years ago as far as you know just
being a tough guy it's tough let me ask
you a um
[Music]
yeah
you know tony's taken some bad head
damage right terrible justin gaichy and
tony's also been doing for a hot second
uh one ninth straight was supposed to
fight
khabib and just never came to fruition
such a bummer because he was the best
one was when did he fight chandler when
did he get knocked out how long ago was
that that's his last fight i know
february
is that right chin i'll look it all
right now because now they just
announced chandler dustin poirier today
that just got announced may 7
what'd i say april february so yeah so
may 7th yeah that's a bit so he's lost
four in a row it's only four months
later i don't know i know i'm not a fan
of it but i don't like it he's lost four
in a row to be fair though at 55 so he
lost to geichi lost to chose charles
oliveira what's his decision that's the
darius killer and the macro like so he's
lost the who's literally one through
five little or one through four at uh
155 they should have stopped that
[ __ ] justin gaichi fight dude tough
man but before that look at the run he
was on dude not those nazos one of the
best runs of ever y'all must have forgot
the ufc goes thanks for all the the the
fights man you're fun to watch you're
going to 70 here's a you know top 15 guy
it's like what
even with nate diaz it's like oh you
want to leave all right you're going to
watch walk through chechnyan [ __ ]
fire i guess
he looked great against chandler like in
the first before he got knocked out yeah
he looked fantastic till he gets clipped
you know
and then with hob like again nadia says
he goes i didn't ask for this [ __ ]
fight because i don't want this fight
said that yeah he was i didn't ask for
those he was ufc said i asked her i
hadn't asked for this [ __ ] fight
he goes but i'll fight anyone i don't
give a [ __ ] what you got to throw you're
like kudos to you brother no he said he
goes he goes the pressure's on him he's
such a badass he's like a big bad badass
he has to finish me he's like the
pressure's on him and he's 100 right
it's just it to me with the uc it's just
not the way to do it it's not the way
you get you pay tribute to these guys it
sucks like nate diaz is i think for the
business i think it's awful i mean nate
diaz it makes no sense in any capacity
if you're the ufc brass you're sitting
around doing match-ups
i would love to hear how you explain
nate diaz who's won one fight in six
years against a
raging surging superstar
at 170. it's like it's it's what seems
like the worst it seems like the biggest
[ __ ] you but but literally it actually
sounds it's it's dangerous yeah it's
like you're here i'll tell you what your
contract's up we're gonna we're gonna
give you the the toughest baddest
[ __ ] who's also huge and he's he
could really really hurt it's not fair
we're gonna do and i know life isn't
fair but it's like dude come on man what
he's done here's my problem is obviously
dana surrounded by yes man how does
somebody not raise her come on dana this
ain't right dude come on give us
somebody the most beloved fighter one of
the most beloved fighters ever in the
u.s how but how does nobody in dana
sergio hold on i just got a question
and you can and um i get the match up
in what capacity do we think that nate a
deserves to fight hamzat b
it does anything for homs that if he
beats them like
if let's say the odd makers are right
and the minus 2200 guy goes in there and
mops the floor with nate what's this
dude from so hamza is expected to
destroy this young man at his age all
the things he's done to the ufc so if
hamza goes in and destroys him i'm sorry
what do we do with them next
what's this do for hamza what's this do
for nate
now to me and i'll go dana to me real
quick don't fire me to me it looks like
you're just trying to
diminish the value of nate diaz before
he leaves am i right on that daniel's
yaga all right then you're doing it
that's the plan you're doing it
puts a real bad taste in my mouth
if i'm the commissioner i go let's make
every fighter feel like complete [ __ ] if
i'm the commissioner no no we're not
doing that
it's the biggest [ __ ] you to nate i
think i i don't i just don't i don't get
the benefit of it well dana said that
nate asked for it no nate came out and
goes i did not ask for this fight i
don't give a [ __ ] i'll fight anybody i
didn't ask for this i've asked for 10
other people they gave him me [ __ ] it if
this is what i have to do to get on my
contract let's do it i'm not scared
because all the pressure's on there
that's that's punishing somebody
the worst way possible the worst way
possible think about it oh you want to
be a fighter actually
it's actually saying this watch this so
i mean this is literally what it is
say i want i want more money i want more
money okay cool i'm going to i'm going
to beat the living [ __ ] out of you
i'm going to beat the [ __ ] out of you
that's kind of what it is
and you're going to get you probably get
savage built some more brain damage and
here's the problem it's not like and
this i'm not throwing shade on tony for
example it's not like if tony gets
clipped by uh the leech they're gonna
stop the fight nate's so tough and his
chin's so good i know this fight is set
up for him to take punishment that's
right need something we can all be
entertained and you when you say chechi
and fire it's probably the best way to
describe it it is chechnya and fire to
me
you know he's going to fight him you
know nate's going to fight him because
nate's a fighter and now to be fair the
fan base the hardcores and just the
general fans went well this makes no
sense why are you giving nate this fight
so dana got a bunch of flack and he was
no no nate asked for this first thing
they said in the interview i didn't ask
for this did you did you talk to rogan
about this
no no
no
no no i you know i'm because rogan said
anything about it he's excited about it
here's the thing b yeah i wouldn't put
rogue in that position because he works
with you
so i it's not that i'm not lucy goose
you know i mean close rogan are but yeah
i could tell let me get away with it but
i'm not going gonna put him in a
position where i'm gonna put him in a
corner where he has to defend that fight
because you know what there's no
defending that fight yeah
and i have all the ammunition i agree
with i can light who who sit me in front
of dana sit me in front of hamzat's
manager i will destroy you on telling me
that this is a fair fight destroy you so
i wouldn't do that well look justin
gates was like nate has zero percent
chance
you know these are all guys who are like
and it's no dis on nate
i don't literally a different weight
class
hold on i don't think he has zero
percent chance you're dealing with it
i'm just telling you what justin had in
his and that's fine
now listen
if we're in reality if we're living in a
normal world it's mma so anything can
happen if we live in a normal world
you know i was talking our boy jesse
today about it jesse jesse on fire you
know great uh mma mind he was asking
this morning is
legit watch this interview one of the
best interviews i've ever seen i watched
it am i okay
and he goes uh
seriously dude if you're gonna bet on
what's what's what odds would you give
it he was ten to one five to one i said
in all honesty if hamzad has learned
from the gilbert fight where he just
fought like a dumbass and still won the
number two guy in the world at
welterweight if everything's normal and
hamzad's in the right frame of mind in
his camp and he's learned from that
gilbert fight fifty to one
fifty to one 50 to 1 [ __ ] odds dude
that's how you want to repay the guy
now
will this fight do well and sell yeah
absolutely
should nate ds fans support it
you want nate diaz get paid right and he
gets part of the pay-per-view so yeah he
probably should yeah but a part of me
goes ah let's show didn't have this
isn't right don't buy the fight it's the
only way is nate done after this does he
go i don't think so he thinks he thinks
he he has another you know mma i think
box and jake he'll fight jake paul
he's making money
but at certain times nate's a
materialistic guy he's not a
money-driven guy he wants to pay what
he's worth but you know he's not a conor
mcgregor he's not on yachts and doing
that [ __ ] it's not his thing he stays in
stockton you know it's not like the
market up there's [ __ ] booming so
he's fine he's not a money-driven guy he
wants what he's paid but it's
i just i don't feel good about it i
don't feel good about promoting i don't
feel good about you know it's just not i
don't think anybody does
i don't think anybody does well i think
dana's doing damage control and was like
oh he asked for this fight it's an ideas
dude he could win this for people saying
nate doesn't have a chance it's like you
know what you're doing
hey hey hey stop stop talk about that
you know what you're doing and then all
the [ __ ] the you know the people that
and remember the ufc controls who's
allowed to ask questions right that's
all predetermined you know this right no
oh yeah it's all
predetermined so if you're going to
fight against the ufc you're not invited
in that's why ariel can't be in there
certain people can't be in there really
oh you don't get credentials bubba oh
wow yeah so
you're only if you play ball you're
allowed to be in that press conference
ask questions so everyone's playing the
game
everyone's gonna sugar coat and go this
is a good thing kick people out and they
can excuse me okay yeah you don't get
credentials they can purify the pool yes
so everyone in there very well-run
company and they're making a lot of
money sure most money they've ever made
every year is the most money you know so
so who am i to criticize them i'm just
saying from uh ethics standpoint this
ain't right
and everybody in that room should be
ashamed of themselves well i i just
everybody in that room in that press
conference should be ashamed no no
because you don't have the balls to go
dana come on dude i know you say he
asked for his fight he came out on
record so you didn't ask for this fight
why would you do this what's the real
reason behind this now you know
and i know this for a fact you know
when um i think gilbert melendez was
fighting they're at a club so just so
you know so when you get done with
ultimate fighter when you get out of the
house dana takes you to a nightclub they
go hey guys great season we're gonna go
to nightclub so you go to vegas night
club everybody goes who is that everyone
goes the whole house goes they pay for
everything you have to even the ones who
are eliminated everyone we all go
because they eliminate the lemonade
fighters can't leave right so it's still
in the house so everyone goes so they
invite you to this uh nightclub
and then they give you money and take
your experiment rhino right i'll never
forget it one of the greatest nights of
my life
but
so nate is on i forget what season but
he's a coach i think gilbert melendez
whatever and so they invite everybody to
that nightclub nate shows up dana's
there and he's drinking
and dana goes what is something like
what's up [ __ ] tonight diaz now
i know from dealing with nate you can't
talk to nate like that it's not going to
go well so dana goes what's up
[ __ ] he's been drinking and he
goes what the [ __ ] is up is you need to
pay me what i'm worth
in his face because you pay what i'm
worth and dan goes what the [ __ ] you
thomas he goes i need big name fights
and you pay me what i'm [ __ ] worth
gets in his face meant to be separated
because nate was going to twist his
[ __ ] neck off
so so the legend of nate diaz i don't
know if that story is out there but the
legend of nate diaz and why you love him
is because of that
that's what you never hear me talk about
about nate
he fights for the fighters and you know
the only reason so when the ufc kept
coming back to him resign with us
re-sign with us nope nope i'm out nope
i'ma fight jake paul do my thing nope
nope nope and then finally nate goes wow
these [ __ ] aren't playing he
goes it seems like we can get away with
a lot and his manager goes yeah you
probably can ask for whatever you want
he goes tell me assign all 10 of my
teammates to the ufc
if he signs all 10 of them i'll keep
fighting i'll resign with them yes sign
all 10 of my guys that train with to the
ufc
and they come back go all right well
we'll put this guy in ultimate fire put
this guy in contentiousness no no no you
have to give him ufc contracts
yes you guys are not going to do that
i'm not resigning
but he's willing to sacrifice
his own future the jake paul payday all
the [ __ ] in order for all 10 of his
teammates to be in the ufc damn that's
why you should root for nate diaz
he's fighting a man he's fighting the
man and here's the thing he's fighting
the man and the bummer is he's not
winning no because he yeah do you ever
win when you fight the man very rarely
i i can't name one and and if you ask
tyrone woodley he goes i wish i never
fought the man it never worked out for
me i would fight say all this stuff they
disciplined me in ways that i didn't
even imagine
they may try to do media i didn't get my
my narrative out there they made they
suppressed everything i did and it
sacrificed sponsorships everything ruin
them ruin them
so that's why you should cheer for an
eight years this weekend
he's fighting the man and the chance not
only does he find the man but i am 51 to
one odds there couldn't be a worse
matchup in the [ __ ] world for this
man if he would you know what i would
give him better odds against francis in
ghana how about that
because at least he could wrestle him
yes
because france doesn't have just at
least he could pull off something
hamza can do it all dude it's so [ __ ]
up but the reason should root for him is
the reasons i just gave you that's why
you should root for an ideas he's
fighting the man dude
and odds are it's not gonna go his way
most likely it's not gonna he's gonna
get absolutely annihilated
but he's dying on his shield that's why
you root for nate diaz that's why we
love nate diaz he's not he's not playing
the game to his point and what he did in
the brett akamoto interview he's not
this guy who wants to be a double champ
and make all this money and be the face
of the ufc he don't give a [ __ ] about
that
he's the anti-man
but that comes with a heavy
heavy price that price is a chechnyan
via sweden
[ __ ] you know one of the best
house we've ever seen and there can be a
worse matchup for nate diaz but and i
love hamza nobody's on his stretching
nuts more than me i i will suck him off
dude i love that dude he i think he's
the future of the ufc i think he'd be
champ at 70 85 and 205 eventually really
but i'm not rooting for him this
saturday yeah and it's not his fault the
ufc has forced me to root against one of
my favorite fighters and nadia's to be
completely honest isn't one of my
favorite fighters i don't think i'm that
intent i don't like the antics all that
[ __ ] but i do like when a guy fights the
[ __ ] man well nate nade to me and
nick i felt the same way the diaz
brothers there's a purity to them and
that purity is that they are about
fighting only they weren't about
business they weren't about they were
they were real they're just
died in the wool fighters they're
fighters before they're athletes they're
fighters before they're businessmen
they're fighters but you want the the
[ __ ] that's about i don't mean
interrupted but you know what the shame
and all that is
is when they're done man they have
nothing to show for it
because what we're learning and why
you're seeing athletes parlay stuff even
while they're current in their careers
because they know it's a short window
because you have to because when you get
done especially in the ufc nfl mlb mba
even though you make more money than god
and if guaranteed money
especially in the
nfl is not all guaranteed but you're
seeing bigger guarantees than ever
they're taking a page of the nba mlb
book so russell wilson just re-signed a
deal with the broncos it's guaranteed
like whatever 265 million dollars
patrick mahomes biggest guarantee of all
time so these guys are smart dude
they're going well hold on
hold on hold on they have the they have
the players union so they're going no
hold on these other leagues are doing
guarantees we want guarantees up front
now we're not taking the oh if you play
this so this may touch [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
i can get injured guarantee me money and
they're doing it now
so but do you see we're we're
so far from that yes so for nate diaz as
much as we love what him and his brother
stand for fighting the man
that story unfortunately does not end
well he might be an exception because
he's so romantic in people's hearts like
exception as far as
sponsorship monetization could how he
doesn't how him and his brother don't
have their own weed business
is beyond me
talking it would sell all the [ __ ]
money and i have the connections for you
guys but still so let's so but they
don't have their own weed business no no
but that i'm sure they've done like
strange what [ __ ] a strain dude you
should be mike tyson has his own weed
and has a felony you guys are good you
can own my mike tyson has known his own
weak on me you can't be a felon and own
a weakness you know this no so he's an
employee of that the diaz brothers don't
have felonies they could be the sole
owners and the amount of people that
would back them and fund that is unbel i
know people have to fund them right now
they'd make all the money in the world
but because they're the diaz brothers
they're not thinking like that and
unfortunately somebody sent this to the
diaz brothers and unfortunately because
they don't think like that
you know ten years from now that road
does not end well dude let's go guys
diaz brothers
it's a blessing and a curse it's a
blessing curse you know yeah it's a
curse and a blast like the blessing is
we all love them but we're not paying
their bills in 10 years when ct sets in
from all the damage
and you're out of your [ __ ] mind if
you don't think those guys have ct in 10
years you're out of your mind most
people do that come from i'm sure i have
a splash of it
i haven't seen it i was going to tell
you about that actually let's talk about
that for a second because i was thinking
about that loud and clear the other day
and you've played football for 13 years
yeah
and uh play football
uh
i started playing tackle football on a
six or six to
stop playing football it's 24. ct is at
the forefront of your mind a lot of
people don't realize not it's not at the
forefront of mine i don't think because
i can't control it yeah but you it's a
thing i joke about it but i'm i'm not
concerned about it but you're probably
sure you have it and a lot of people do
i actually was thinking about this the
other day because i was
listening to your talk and i was
listening to the things you were saying
and then i was thinking about the the
podcast we'd do with rogan for four and
a half hours
and then we hung out and you were really
tired i wasn't tired i was upset b no no
i know i don't know at the end of the
night when we
got back
we were told i'm exhausted yeah we were
both exactly what i'm trying to say i
wanted to get a drink i was like dude
i'm [ __ ] excited what i'm trying to
say is that you're
like that would be when you'd start to
see some stuff and i've seen ct on some
people right
and um i don't think i don't think
you have any of it
and i'm a doctor
so
you're welcome i i it might come it
might rear it's ugly no i'm just telling
you when i have conversations about
strategy and we talk about things and we
talk about and i watch the way you're
you know a lot of times you can hear it
in slurs like you had a speed you have a
speech impediment i've had that since i
know that so i'm i'm paying it like i
was looking at old [ __ ] that we did and
now now i'm looking at this it's not
though it's not you speak actually more
clearly because you are aware of clearly
not because i became aware of it because
i talked for a living that's what i'm
saying so so
if anything has gotten better and that's
not what happens a lot of times so it's
interesting because you have uh
you you know you it's very interesting
that you've done so much sports and i we
we're at a table with a bunch of black
belts and jiu-jitsu and other things
everybody's injured everybody's injured
and they've done a fraction of the
amount of physical [ __ ] he's done
and he doesn't have any injuries no knee
i could run a tough battle every week no
neck no elbow you know why they'll be
because to them
it's to them maybe whatever jiu jitsu's
life but it's not it's not paying their
bills i did as a professional but even
if i wasn't a professional athlete for a
number of years
i've been in gym since i was five years
old my dad took me to gym when i was
five so the gym is my life you might
have a very sturdy body jim's my life my
dad's never injured we just don't my
brother's never injured strong
but we've all we grew up like mark knows
this like
i just you know i've built this you've
never stopped working out
you've never stopped working out never
but also to the point of ct i don't mark
or realize this my brother will know
this
every time i get off stage every single
time i do over an hour of stand up i
look at my brother and mark go ct my ass
and walking are you two every single
time
come on baby what's up daddy come on but
also you gotta remember a lot of these
guys they stopped
reading they stopped doing like they
stopped firing those nerves when are you
gonna stop stealing jokes yeah right
exactly i'm gonna piss out of my dick
i'm dying are you dying i'm dying hot
outside how was the malibu chili coke
off oh well we haven't seen each other
see any celebrities
the tmz was there they were all over me
but um
my dad my tiger goes dad who are they
i'm like they're just they just want to
picture your dad dude be cool i was like
just keep moving too don't stop she's
like who are you guys like no don't do
that just keep going
now your boy um your boy
um dude boston looks just like his
brother when he was younger they looked
just like oh my god my little minnie
mies
so you know they love they call them
stuffy stuffed toys so we walk in you
know how it is you've been there there's
all those carnival games with the
stuffed toys so t goes dad let's get
stuff toys i'm like well you just can't
buy him he was just buy something no you
got to win them so he goes let's not go
on rides just get the stuffed toys my
god damn it but your boy was on i went
four for four i went forward before you
see the big one
[Music]
easy dude that is not easy
but you're so hot
oh i'm sweating i'm sweat dripping off
my nose right it put put the the volume
up gin
i see do you think it's fair that
because you're so small after you're on
all the rides with you and i don't fit
on them
yeah you think that's nice because yeah
you think that's good boss
oh
okay i can't feel my legs
i'm in this
i know exactly where you're at
i know exactly what training and the guy
goes around like the conductor everybody
goes you think you're gonna fit i'm like
oh can you ride by himself because
absolutely not i go well it doesn't
matter then i'll force myself a favor it
doesn't matter and then we're on the
swings you know the swing thing that
flips or like goes
flips around
all right i thought you had to like
i couldn't get the mine was broke so i
couldn't lift the the like strap up so i
was like oh you gotta jump into it so
you'll boss them back up and they're
showing they'll buy back up dude that's
gonna jump in and i'll pick you up and
he goes okay papa he doesn't go enough
are you dude back up i'm gonna jump in
if it swings you're gonna [ __ ] hit
it's okay papa so i'm like folks all
right go to jump in of course it swings
boom right in the face
he's crying like death people are
looking at me i'm like
i tell boston dude he's so loud are you
a bro you have got to quit crying i want
happy bosty
if you if you don't stop crying we're
not going on the rides he goes no i want
to go i want to go on the ride i'm like
that's what i thought who is that gal is
that katy perry you're hugging no that's
freaking laura i wish i knew katy perry
right katy perry is not going to food
trucks she's not funny who is that now
well laura senko
go ahead and play that brian the future
of ufc commentary you know her brian
it's an absolute super strong dana
white's contender series it's laura
senko we flew her all the way from
kansas city to feed her she was a
fighter
[Music]
she's good too oh so she is so the only
reason i had her on i mean obviously
she's a gorgeous girl but
so talented
that's so cool she's so dope she's so
good at her job she's like wifey
material oh yeah 100 call of duty is
she's headed she's a unicorn no she's a
unicorn i've watched her i'm i was
watching i'm like who is this who is
this gal because you know me you know
unless you really know fine i don't love
to talk fighting yeah but so i figured
you know she knows fighting was a job
like
you know i've interviewed before when
we've got fox some of the nfl girls who
work don't really know football right
and i'm like okay you're just a pretty
face
dude
she knows her [ __ ] she fought yeah you
bring it up you're like oh my god that's
why i told him you're a unicorn and
she's like oh i love it and i was like
if the ufc don't pay anymore you know
like the nfl bay is going to come
calling she's like i don't care all i
care about is fighting all i know is
amazing she's she's such a badass she's
a badass superstar so she's interesting
because she was fighting got pregnant
and was like well i
can't become champ if i'm pregnant
because i gotta dedicate my life to my
kid i don't want to be you know because
she's like you know fighting like it's
going to take that's all you have to
care about she gave up her fighting
career and then uh she was sitting
around the house and then the invicta
which is the female league the biggest
female league the invicta lady who owns
it called her goes hey can you interview
she goes i've never been on camera i've
never interviewed anybody anybody there
we feel like you have to look for it
you'll feel it out
she's so strong like that a natural
beast and then dana white contender
series starts she's on there she's the
first female ever to do play
play-by-play commentating for a
professional ufc fight crushes it there
so now the next step for her and the ufc
dare god they need to do it is get her
as on the on a pay-per-view or a fight
now yeah and she should get there
she's such a savage jeez and just a good
person well she thought you know also
that's a huge thing like maybe she's
still trying to stay that's a lot yeah
trains all the time there you go crazy
shape
oh
she's like i'm out of shape i think
yeah her waist is like this big oh she's
she's a unicorn man yeah
yeah she's so dope too such a good
person yeah she was really cool to talk
to that's us hugging brian
be cool
yeah
she talked about it too like she wants
to make sure she puts training videos in
there as well because so people know
that she's not just like a no she's like
she's [ __ ] legit
yeah i'm a huge fan and she's
she's she has like a farm or something
right she works she lives on a farm yeah
bodybuilder
the one of her running chain what is
that
running though oh yeah she's sweaty
all right fine let's see if there's
music five and a half mile sunday run as
usual different day
but i'm gonna continue being ready
yeah she's
yeah yep she's stunning and she's great
and she's awesome at her job she's like
freaking out she's she's so she's going
to be the first like when she takes over
like like one of these desk spots at the
commentating like like uh dana called
her the ronda rousey of commentating
like she's the the girl who's gonna set
the package all females like little
girls gonna grow up looking up to laura
sanko like she's such a beast she's so
good at her job and you called her the
the horse gracie basically i said hold
on they keep saying you're running
around you're hoist grace yeah yeah
you're the first first
she's incredible yeah it's a fun food
truck too
oh we got a big food truck next week
baby
can you say
i won't yet i hate to announce it early
you never know [ __ ] you never know
who knows a [ __ ] nuclear bomb never
too late putin has a heart attack and
launches a new game he cancels the food
but i'll tell you what it's never late
too late for it's never too late to
watch man tears guys oh my god now
on youtube and so you enjoyed it right
enjoyed what he's special yeah yeah
he's my boy i've been waiting i've like
i've been wanting to watch it like maybe
on my phone or something like that i'm
gonna i'm waiting until luanne can watch
it with me on the big screen he's been
out of week that's all right she also
loves your comedy i told you last time
we saw you live she was like screaming
to the point of embarrassing me i'm like
i've gotten some good reviews i have to
say so but you know now i got to start
all over again i'm trying to write
pushing a wheel up a hill pushing wheels
up a hill painting that's never done
you're gonna see a lot of new stuff san
jose and raleigh and [ __ ] spokane and
tacoma let's go
one week after another oh dude i'm on
the road every week every [ __ ]
september my grandma went you're on the
road every week i'm gonna pass away and
then we're gonna do the memorial on your
only weekend so you're gonna come to
denver during your only weekend off i
went say less grandma
there it is i'm flying out there there
it is there you are appleton first then
ontario and it weird once you shoot a
special nothing drives me more nuts when
a comic shoots a special and they go on
tour and they still do bits
from the special
how dare you
now if you're jerry seinfeld or jay leno
who don't shoot specials well jerry
seinfeld has the same social twice he
released but they don't believe in
specials
they believe people it's like like i
talked to jayla one person at the car
show all the same they're all time the
one that canceled you suck malibu cafe
but they uh
uh jay leno goes yeah we i don't believe
in it you never never want to shoot
especially because no no he goes uh when
you go see aerosmith right he's older i
was like i'd never go to aerosmith but
he goes theo smith do you want to see
them do new songs
oh no suck yours here you wanna see the
classics
i don't agree with him at all but that's
okay yeah that's kind of like the
analogy and then jay leno goes
look at my bank account shut your phone
right he doesn't need to fair points sir
like aerosmith also released albums
you know elena was never a guy i looked
up too comedically but that's oh he's he
was a beast though and jay leno was the
guy for the comedy story remember the
comedy store if you played comedy store
you couldn't play the improv he was like
no no i'm doing whatever i want he's
such a
a savage they couldn't tell him no yeah
and when the the comics went on strike
he was like the main guy like he was a
beast back in the day yeah but i get
what you're saying as far as rules for
him right successful guy good guy super
successful yeah good guy you know he's
never spent a dime a dime from the money
that makes for the tonight show
yeah i know never that annoys me but
yeah well i mean but it's like oh but
you make 100 million stand up yeah you
can't you couldn't spend that money i'm
just using this giant pile of money and
saving this other giant pile of money
for later i you know i don't know that
well i'm like what do you do with all
that man
you're looking for donations have a go
fund yeah
you do i don't but i'll start one up if
you're going to donate
a 10 mil so i can chill out
let's watch this
let's let's go to let's go to current
events
the harry styles thing oh it got me i
just saw it it got me distracted if i
was just chilling my nuts were hanging
out yes vodka dude that reminds me shout
out to denver post you ever seen that
article
of the guy whose house burnt down and
he's on the fr and someone just missed
it just you know things happen he's in
short jean shorts and he's sitting on
like a [ __ ] milk carton because his
house burned down behind him and his
nuts are hanging out i sure have it's
like we saw it on the show it's like it
couldn't have gotten any worse for the
band and then
someone running the paper puts him on
the front post and his nuts are hanging
out that's a dead baby bird oh no this
you're nuts like sir we're so sorry your
house burnt down but real quick do you
mind if we make you the laughing stock
of america by putting you damn it's
sitting here sad oh you got put in
denver chin yep denver yeah it's denver
post i mean we we've done this before
listen dude we've done so many [ __ ]
shows just giving us i didn't see this
denver post
man's nuts hanging out front cover
denver post man's knocked
hanging out there it is
what oh you got it go ahead but it got
popped up
anybody remember this unfortunately the
story was nuts
there you
go you see these balls to the left of
the house dude sorry
sorry bro sorry man oh god oh it's
actually rocky mountain rocky mountain
news there's his ball residents return
he's just as nuts he's all god damn it
dude but does he don't have underoos on
you know there was a picture where it
shows it showed it more yeah you saw it
before he had no time
how funny is that somebody got fired
yeah anyways
imagine pushing my knots right here
right now youtube would be all heavy
just
just a heavy route
oh this little thing oops oh your shorts
are so short dude i know they're so
short a lot of your legs that's how i do
it dude you would too if you have these
[ __ ] teardrops
there you go
by the way brent you like all this like
murder crazy stuff yeah you gotta watch
you gotta watch like brian watch before
old boy the korean movie old boy
and um is there subtitles yes nope you'd
like to like
squid game right
paradise i enjoyed squeezing so that's
what i'm saying like give it a shot see
paris paris
okay so you might want to watch never
seen that and i saw the devil no
nationally yeah never saw parasite no i
have seen it
wow
you love that moment dude i guarantee
you just watch
watch wow and don't ask anyone about it
just watch it dude don't look it up
don't google it just watch old boys
that's a crazy good movie it's so good
we'll blow your mind is on netflix just
you got to see the one of those see the
korean versions
yeah not the american version no no you
don't want to do that version sucks
it'll blow your mind actually you
especially it is so insane oh boy trust
me insane trust your family parasite how
about paris yeah they're all [ __ ] that's
a good movie whoa have you noticed one
it won the academy award for have you
ever seen parasite no it won the academy
of war no because the one academy were
in hollywood's like
sounds like i'm out no anything
hollywood loves i'm out but also this
was a foreign feature that they're
folding into the best picture category
for the first time ever because there's
all sorts of but it was so good and
unique and so is old boy where i think
same director
i think so yeah i don't trust anything
i don't trust anything hollywood
three movies for me of all time oh i
mean it's it's it's one of the best
movies ever you just like you watch it
and you're like some people are so smart
and talented it's so fun and also
brendan god that's such a good you would
you would like it because of the
darkness and the human
parasite
i'm saying
old boy
old boy it's actually genius if you're
not going to watch it it's unusual no
i'll watch it you gotta watch it go buy
this book though you told me about one
thing at a time man okay old boy but
don't look up anything don't go there
while we're in appleton wisconsin that's
not a bad idea they can watch that yeah
yeah what if jason once you watch it
once you watch it you're gonna go you're
gonna go like you can't watch five
minutes of it you're gonna wait a minute
oh it's so good
you know what i do on the road i just
watch the same show over and over i
watch um
i watch uh mine hunter over and over
yeah well you gotta watch both seasons i
would watch these two movies yeah and i
i saw the devil just
i saw the devil too many too many two
there's only three let me do old boy and
hold on first because old boy's the
oldest one we'll go we'll go boys first
yeah i know we're going to talk about
another
that's how i was parasite
both deep in korean movies now yeah
yeah that's what i was going to say all
right all right so the whole hairstylist
thing it's kind of weird
so you know that hairstyles is
i guess allegedly dating olivia wilde
allegedly they're together i mean oh
yeah so they've they've been caught
together holding hands together so yeah
she's showing uh her man she apparently
cheated on jason sudeikis yeah i believe
he served her papers during a live
broadway play so
that happened but then during this new
movie that she directed during a
premiere of it
um this is i'll sh i'll play the video
she's gorgeous by the way well she's of
course i used to see her all the time
so this chris pine right here in the
middle right guy chris pines why is he
dressed like the riddler
so look again
so it looks like he's he's just funny it
looks like chris oh sorry it looks like
hairstyles yeah it looks like hairstyles
spit on chris pine and you can see him
like stop doing he's alright let me see
spit his gum watch
[Music]
oh he did so chris pine's like uh and
chris pine goes
yeah and also harry styles is laughing
of course sitting away from it's an
inside joke
seems like just [ __ ] around
everyone's like oh drama no this is very
youtube red in general like drama yeah
everybody see harry styles spit on like
yeah they're bros yeah it looks like he
spit like some gum or something
right there
he stops
wish you could see the gum though
you can't see anything it's hilarious i
think he's funny as [ __ ] hairy style
seems like an awesome guy that clip
makes me want to cut my hair because my
chris pine looks so much better with
harry styles he does
he's got a sense of humor
yeah chris pine for usually chris pine's
a dying piece and i like longer hair
i've seen that i'm like daddy looks
awful yeah
what did he win for here for his role
no no this is a premiere that's premiere
yeah no they're clapping because there's
a big collar but also it's kind of like
people think something happened because
chris pine is sitting next to olivia
wilde and then you know chris is in
between harry styles and they well so
maybe since she cheated on freaking her
man before who knows if she hooked up
hey chris
i'm just saying this is what the
internet's running wow but then also
those movies
yeah i agree but his hair don't ever
wear that again also you look like a
shitty matrix brad pitt with your hair
like that but um the other problem is
with this movie there's so much drama
around it right because she met harry
styles on set cheated on her man there
and then also they made the buff walked
off the movie
and she came out during the whole meetup
movies like oh because allegations
against homegirl um we can't have part
of this movie and then uh shia labeouf
goes no hold on i quit because homegirl
was a [ __ ] i don't want to work with her
and then he released a video of her
begging him to stay on this film he said
i just can't i can't work
i remember uh shia labeouf says i'm like
he just didn't want to be a part of
because of her but then she said that
she didn't like his demeanor yeah she
said he was difficult yeah yeah
and then he released a video being like
none of that happened yeah he said it
was because she wasn't giving the actors
enough rehearsal time for these
difficult scenes are really long it's
like she's getting too much [ __ ] for you
know nothing no she's too pretty to give
her that much but also maybe she's lying
safe for the ugly ones she's awesome
she's also a good director yeah i'm a
fan of her you don't like her chin no
because i don't like anyone that cheats
on you know she didn't you don't know
the story oh my gosh come on dude
what's going on but you don't know they
don't apparently you know so jason just
brought his kids
they're in hollywood they never see each
other literally when you're jason
zedekis and you're her and then you
don't see him
here's what happened though so jason we
don't know what happened no this one no
one knows
let me tell you what he thinks happened
jason sodegas brought his kids on set to
visit the you know the mother yeah you
know his wife
and then so they felt weird because they
knew something was happening with him
and that's why the other girl doesn't
know but that's to be honest to chin's
point to back that point upbeat come on
brian that other girl that shyla buff
had an issue with she won't promote or
talk about the movie because she doesn't
like the way for the longest time yeah
yeah she's like she showed up to a
couple like it's so weird she won't
promote the movie and she'll be part of
it because she didn't like the way
olivia wilde handled the jason sadega
situation now i don't even believe that
now here's the problem here's the
problem i don't judge any guy or girl
who teaches them significant other
because i don't know what the [ __ ] the
details are so like neo got busted
cheating right or or homeboy with khloe
kardashian i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened i have no clue what they're
dealing with especially when you get
kids involved like who knows and they
could have an agreement with an open
relationship or when i'm on set you know
if i'm a different area code i can suck
some big black dick i don't know what
the deal is who knows i don't know that
you can no i can't we can't but i'm
saying olivia wildcat i'm not buying
anything the press says about this [ __ ]
i'm looking at this particular situation
because hollywood [ __ ] surprise i'm
looking at this particular situation as
a a single thing because
he served her papers while she's on
stage because he's so bitter about what
happened no no no no no he has no
control he has no he
yeah me and brian are a little older
than we've been through older
no but we're married right with kids so
when you serve someone you don't have
any kids i used to be a process server
just so you know you have no control
when it happens you should i do
when she's on stage that's not how it
works i don't know right have you ever
worked worked as a process server i know
a lot about it
but i know but he's done it i'm telling
you that if you say otherwise you're
wrong
he's done it i don't give a [ __ ] say you
don't want to make something like you're
talking about no that doesn't work
they'll be here because it does i'm
sorry
guys when you serve so when someone is
have you been serving i've been certain
no have you been through it i've never
i've been served have you been serving
no but i've
[Music]
or papers what happens is especially if
you're a celebrity is they're very hard
to get in touch with so what always
happens they go the only time i'm going
to be able to get close to that person
we know they're going to be happy
it's when they're at that date okay so
the server so when you say it goes
through a process
he's not saying hit her when she's there
no no no yeah yeah you're right right
i'm with you on that no he didn't say
that we're saying the server knew
exactly so he could that's what here's
what the the server also came out and
said i regret doing that or like oh they
got it
the choice could be vegas sure he knows
when she's at different locations but he
chose to pick this particular one like
he okay this is where this is the best
place to serve her the only time he
could yeah they're close to us there's
no there's touch them there's other
times too though bro that they could
serve i've served so many different
times in different areas yes i know but
what i'm saying is they had tried many
many times i think though the main point
here is like i'm sure he was upset there
wasn't like a
open relationship where she could bone
other dudes it was more like we don't
know i'm hollywood's chris i'm going off
i'm going off of what i'm seeing here so
this is what i'm thinking but we don't
know yeah we don't know this is what you
should think that's why i don't know i
mean i like what you're doing it's like
will smith
it's like will smith and jay smith it's
like she had her side piece bringing
around family vacation i don't know i
don't know i don't know their agreement
i don't know to me i'm like oh that i
would never do that's insane
to them that's their agreement but you
know what i think
when i see uh jada pinkett and and will
smith i i see a couple that have made
that relationship work for a long
[ __ ] time how about that i see about
giving some oh not me i i i see a lady
who took advantage of him i see a lady
that has it her way if it goes the other
way she freaks the [ __ ] out i see a lady
that pushed him to slap chris rocky he's
still embarrassed by this yeah he's
responsible for his own did you see that
video of jada pink and smith going in
the video sorry there was another one
where she talks about will smith
creating this uh 40th birthday party and
she was like it was the most
narcissistic thing he's like i planned
this birthday party for three years and
you were like you're disgusting how dare
you make my birthday all about you it
was like
it was extremely telling have you ever
seen when she goes live on instagram and
he goes in the kitchen the [ __ ] are you
doing she goes no hon you got he goes
hold up let me what are you doing but he
i don't want to be on your [ __ ] block
possible he's like social media is my
bread and butter and i'd really
appreciate it if you gave me a little
heads up before you put me in yes he's
like could you just wait till i make my
smoking legs yeah that's that's going to
be oh she's a [ __ ] that's pretty cool
i would say that that's somebody who's
who
has a never-ending need for attention
and they might both be that way and
there's a competition sometimes when two
people like that are under the same
rules well there's no competition but
yeah yes that's why they said which then
builds somewhat animosity resentment and
also that's why they say you can only
have one headshot in the household
but her headshot is the red table talk
right and he's in bad boy seven
right what's up so there's not much
where is red table uh aired where
facebook because they pay her you know
part their
they turn their whole house upside down
to film that once a week and he has to
walk by where she's talking about
sucking tupac's dick that's his life
brian
like that's what they always say you may
think that guy over there has a better
life than you but if you get real close
to it you might change oh no his life's
better yeah
no no [ __ ] will smith his life is so
much better than ours yeah do you think
so oh no i mean him slapping he still he
could just be like oh hollywood [ __ ] off
and then ride into the sunset with a
golden horse yeah
right what do you do on that golden
horse though after a while because you
ride in your giant mansion get a
helicopter and you make sweet instagram
videos like he's doing i don't know it
sounds like i'm bored
but think about he's been hollywood he's
been creating 30 years 30 years
you're all set dude i agree ooh what is
this so this is a
i guess an interesting conversation
no so if a girl if your girl wore like a
really tiny
yeah
there's dads around here what are you
trying to do oh no there's kids also
there's a bunch of kids let me see this
so this is what happened here and then
this girl it became viral because the
girl said is this okay to do in a family
location
for a family water park or not
is she there with her kid
she's with her boyfriend but there's a
bunch of kids around
yeah i would say it's distasteful like
you don't need to do that
and that's not a that's a string bikini
that works
so for the the audible audible listeners
really got a girl in you know like the
wave pool and she's in a string bikini
with a jigsaw well not a string bikini
right that's like one piece with a thong
basically that's normal
tommy is covered tommy's covered uh her
breasts are covered but she she did it
is a thong
right up here it's america the girl next
to her it's got a few inches more
swimsuit on that's considered
appropriate where the difference isn't
that funny though so there's a
difference right so one inch one inch
nobody bats an eye and then an inch in
it's about two inches uh less fabric and
everybody's more excited you'll see her
cheeks inside i'm just saying that's to
the right is considered a normal bathing
suit yeah
part of it's also because she's got a
great ass and so it's sexually
suggestive no one loves a nice jumper
more than me right yeah but i'm sorry am
i at hooters listen if you're in a
string bikini at my kids [ __ ] pool
party you got you gotta come on you know
what you're doing right you're doing
this blasting i think it's fine uh kids
see a lot more than that if my girl was
like before he went out like what are
you doing yeah like there's kids there's
dad like we don't want this to touch
it's about the kids what are you doing
yeah now she's there without her kids
she's with her boyfriend also what are
you guys doing but you know yeah
baby why would you go to uh why would
you go to a water park with your
boyfriend right it's a kid's thing
yeah it's a parent thing
it might be a first date buddy weird
first date yeah that's a crazier state
all right so this is um someone tagged
us in this but this is from no jumper
apparently instagram has banned all
pornhub accounts across their platform
um
the main ig account with 13 million
followers has been deleted so i guess
visa and mastercard
they won't let people that own those
cards buy anything from pornhub anymore
oh but i can buy jewelry from blood
diamonds you're fine with it massively
because of a child pornography thing
though well you know well
suspended all the porn all porn stars
stupid accounts how stupid is that
they they they were like no
you make money off of porn it's like
[ __ ] off wells fargo
so basically someone on that apparently
was 13 years old was on a pornhub site
and i guess their mother company or
their network
their like visa and mastercard are not
allowing people to pay for that site
anymore because they say that they knew
about this happening yeah yeah i don't
know yeah anytime soon how can you how
can you like there's so many
what millions of videos out there how
can you tell when something's going i
don't know
so i don't know
but it's just a weird hard line to dive
into right yeah i mean we don't know
enough about it so
but that was interesting um
this one here vegas magic show patreon
mastermind's backstage hey that's
awesome
is that a comedy show oh so basically
the laugh factory in vegas i don't know
if you guys ever played there
i haven't you haven't no they actually
happened they asked you to do tuesday
through sunday
so there this is a fetish there are
people yeah so this is magician no no
murray the magician
someone walked in backstage and took his
clothes
brought it with him and started
mastering him with his clothes that's
what fetish people do they do weird [ __ ]
do you have a video of this yeah there
is video someone took my clothes dressed
like people
this is a weird fetish people break into
people's houses and jerk off in the
closet serial killers do it they jack
after the murder stage correct they come
back to the murderer you sure know a lot
about that brian that's how they thought
that that's how they caught the green
river killer correct right so this guy
oh this is what he's into
so he's snuck in he's backstage where
the magician hangs yep well he grabs his
clothes he gets that he pulls his cape
and then just starts jacking it uh-huh
well this guy gets problems
well it's a gay man right he's gonna
vape they're not gonna show us much but
he so he grabbed his clothes earlier and
then started jacking off so is he
wearing the magician's clothes no he
just grabbed it earlier he just smelled
it you know smells like this later he
wants to masturbate so you see he got
the clothes here and did he ejaculate
actually he might be wearing the clothes
bro yeah maybe
because it looks different a lot of
times you just put on somebody else's
clothes and you jerk that little rouge
interesting all right yeah that's like
wherever you're going to buddy it's like
a little room
right yeah all right la rouge
all right uh the first one we got here
judge orders
white house turnover emails fauci
jean-pierre sent big tech so they are a
couple
attorney generals collusion are suing
the biden administration
uh with the allegation that there was
some sort of collusion between
big tech and the white house as far as
censoring
oh well we know we know the white house
for a fact contact twitter and facebook
yeah yeah and that's really coming out
as
you know
is something that's beyond just
conspiracy obviously people have been
saying this for a while but it could be
that there's hard evidence that they've
censored any dissenting opinions about
the mainstream copenhagen yeah if you're
just coming privy to this you're an
idiot and stuff that is now accepted is
truth yes
yes so we may very well learn some very
interesting things
um so you know why they say that he said
masks don't work in the beginning was
because he didn't want
uh he didn't want anybody they were
afraid they'd run out of masks for first
responders yeah and that's fair but now
you can't trust anything he says yeah
that's a lie right should we lie in any
line of now you're like now you land
them yeah you know which time are you
lying away you've lied to the public so
yeah
but you promised you're telling me don't
get me stuck on that
i'll get this whole show flag mark
mark zuckerberg had some very
interesting things to say about all this
on in this interview i thought it was
really interesting
missing teen found give us one more chin
i get a roll okay
oh yes this one's super interesting um
a couple really interesting true crime
ones today uh so
this guy in las vegas it's like a city
controller or some sort of uh you know
an administrative official
um his home was raided because there was
a this reporter writing these scathing
stories about him and and his oversight
of the office
uh he loses the election because of
these stories then a few weeks later
the guy who wrote the stories this you
know six-year-old journalist is found
dead in his home damn and uh it's a
little bit suspicious so the home of las
vegas county administrative official was
rated by cops wednesday in connection
with the fatal stabbing of local
investigative reporter jeff german whom
he had previously accused of targeting
him in a smear campaign
um do you have video of him against dad
german a 69 year old las vegas review
journal reporter had spent months
reporting on the turmoil surrounding
telus's oversight of the office
including allegations of emotional
stress bullying and favoritism
and threats of stabbing just kidding
according to the island the
administrator 45 had lost his
re-election bid in june's primary
election in the wake of germans
reporting being published and he kept
tweeting he's wearing gloves and a large
hat he's just tweeting stuff like wife
hears rust in the trash uh
honey is there a wild animal in the
trash and he says no dear look it looks
like the reporter going through our
trash for his fourth story on me oh jeff
and so he killed him
it it would seem so because again a 69
year old investigative journalist i'm
sure he doesn't have
you know he's like he's involved in
organized crime or something yeah um
that's him with the crazy eyes and
yellow teeth
stabbed that's yeah that's that's the
journalist right there that sucks and uh
that's uh the guy doesn't look
suspicious i know that's like super
suspicious that that's amazing
do you if you have time for one more
there's a crazy one yeah all right he
gives one more so let's not end on that
one missing teen gabriel michael davies
found safe then arrested for murder this
is a wild story he went from missing
person to the subject of a murder
investigation basically amen this kid
goes missing
missing for a few days
uh they don't know where he is he's like
16 they find his car and it's like
crashed and the there's blood inside and
the says washington state teenager who
vanished on his way to football practice
last week has been accused of plotting
his own disappearance to avoid being
arrested for the murder of his mother's
ex-boyfriend
gabriel davey 16 was reported missing by
his family after failing to show up for
football practice probably not a very
good player authorities had launched a
frantic search for the teen when they
found his car abandoned with blood
smeared inside his cell phone shattered
on the ground but in strange turn of
events
officials revealed davis was found safe
on september 1st under suspicious
circumstances
just an hour later ended up nabbing him
and his friends on murder charges over
the death of 51 year old daniel
mcconnell so he and his friends did it
just because why did they do it
he's a handsome kid his life's [ __ ]
yeah prosecutors say the alleged
elaborate orchestrated saga started to
unravel when authorities discovered
mccall's rotting body shot and stabbed
to death inside his ording home earlier
in september first after he failed to
show up for work several days later
determined that mccall has been in
previous relationships with davey's mom
amanda and that the three had once lived
together victim's home a couple had just
split just weeks before the murder
officials also became suspicious of
dave's after he's located by search
teams roughly 36 hours after being
reported missing
close to where authorities found his
abandoned car he did it with his friends
yeah and then the plot thickens because
his dad is alleging
like
he's like yeah okay
sure he there's a surveillance footage
of the kid and his buddy like coming out
of the guy's house with like guns and
ammo and he's like no no um it was the
guy's biker friends that made him go in
and steal stuff like the whole story is
very conscious mccall's home that
alleges show davies and yoon crawling
through a doggy door in the early hours
wearing gloves well he's [ __ ]
i was an asian dude
yeah and he's like oh no that's who did
it well him and the asian dude and the
the son i think it's funny that they
make uh the criminals were mad oh god
okay man before you're sentenced to to
lie for murder let's make sure you don't
get covered yeah 16 year olds what a
surprise oh their life's over man they
left a trail dude i was watching the
show on netflix i forget what it is oh
i'm a killer they have news they've got
their news never seen that it's good you
know after the first meeting like all
right but um they have one on there with
this guy
he was down and out on his luck he was
hiring meth he had two kids and a wife
and he took us
like 16 year old hostage and the cops
are chasing he gets to an airport where
there's a plane and this uh pilot goes
hey let the kid go i'll take his spot if
you're gonna take a hostage take me
don't take the 16 year old his whole
life out of them you're like okay cool
say les
he goes in there he's on the plane
he didn't realize at the time when the
the the he was on the plane he thought
he was he's just you know he's high in
meth he's not thinking you know clearly
he thinks oh i can just fly to another
county i'll get away from this [ __ ] but
as he's negotiating with the hostage
negotiator there's people under the
plane taking the air out of the tires of
the plane can't fly off and he's like he
realized that and then he poked us out
of the door to negotiate sniper boom
chest shoots from the chest doesn't kill
him he goes oh hell no he said he just
reacted shot the pile in the head kills
him
so he was like 16 or 18 when that
happened he gets life in prison
so they're interviewing him and he's an
older wiser man i guess i wish that was
the worst day of my life i don't know
what the [ __ ] i was thinking he goes but
is it fair
when you're when you do something you're
16. your brain's not i'm going to that's
what he said he goes i'm in prison for
the rest of my life
for one mistake
he was in a horrible mistake i get
somebody's life was taken but should i
be put down because you're such a
different person that's why he said he
goes i'm much wiser now like i wish i
could talk to that kid because my life
is ruined yeah he goes if i can get out
i can be much more benefit to society
telling people like
don't let one situation dictate the rest
of your life and as he's talking like
you kind of get it of course but then
they show the family of the pilot who
died you like gas will get their side
well
that's why the show's good if you're 16
there's a reason there's juvenile
detention your brain isn't fully
developed i think it was 18 so he went
to big boy prison yeah that's tough
holding the homies pockets
you know i want you to hold my pocket
what hold up okay
guys and let's go see brennan in
appleton wisconsin september
i'm waking up at 3 a.m foreign tomorrow
literally i need to go pack and get on
the [ __ ] flight and you're in the
ontario improv september 15th appleton
wisconsin's this thursday friday
saturday and then los angeles hollywood
uh shop and friends uh at the hollywood
improv in la's one night one show only
at 8 p.m september 13th that same night
my shows at eight i will also be at the
comedy store sam tripley in the main
room with santino some other great
comics
but the tour comes back in ontario
california ontario improv september 15th
through the 17th and i end september in
boston boston september 29th through
october 1st those tickets almost sold
out thursday through friday laugh boston
boston and then just announced we just
added san jose salt lake city all great
grand wonderful but calgary canada we
came to an agreement your boys come to
canada first time like five years i'm in
calgary canada
one night only october 27th the thursday
night in calgary canada tickets just
went on sale go get them you savages
love calgary thanks man i've been in
calgary many times um kids raleigh this
weekend tomorrow september 8th 9th and
10th and i got san jose california
improv september 15 16 17. specan
washington's special comedy club
september 22 23 24 tacoma washington
tacoma comedy club september 29 30
october 1. get your [ __ ] tickets
let's go
is that it that's it this is the fine
kid we're out